für zehn millionen deutsche wurde jetzt
kurzarbeit angemeldet wir haben uns auf
den straßen in deutschland um gehört war
genau denjenigen davon jetzt betroffen
sind die momentanen situation ist
bisschen schwierig also mit 60 prozent
kurzarbeitergeld ist es sehr schwierig
zurzeit geht es noch aber ich denke wenn
sich zweiter zieht dann hat man sehr
viele ängste wie soll man alles bezahlen
ja ich bin barbetreiber einer bar in
stuttgart und selbstverständlich sind
auch wir von der kurzarbeit betroffen
wir mussten alle unsere mitarbeiter
unsere fest angestellte in kurzarbeit
schicken und wir haben auch sehr viele
studentische angestellt und manager war
die jetzt leider wohl gar keinen mehr
versuchen ja krone bei mir zur folge ich
bin leiter eines städtischen
kulturhauses da ja bis auf weiteres alle
veranstaltungen abgesagt sind sieht es
bei mir jetzt ab exakten kosten 15 so
aus dass mein kollege und mitarbeiter im
kulturhaus und auch ich beide erstmal in
kurzarbeit gehen ich habe im november
meine arbeit aufgegeben um perspektiven
bis weiter zuschauen
hätte ich das gewusst hätte ich das
natürlich nicht gemacht ja und jetzt bin
ich in der arbeitslosigkeit und schon
viele absagen erhalten aufgrund des
coronas definitiv hat eine sehr gute
ausbildung würde wieder angesiedelt
werden definitiv sagt die agentur für
arbeit auch aber es ist gerade ein ding
der unmöglichkeit